my name is d500 3
I am a citizen of a single state of the city
happiness and harmony
[music]
always
us
I have a
mustache
and
[music] a
terrible woman
who on I have not seen her before what and you need to
leave you the soul was formed you are the
blood and flesh of the
city under the dome and beautiful  dresses and
perfumes they destroyed a billion people
women ruined for no passion look
state 200 years and as far as we knew the
benefactor was
only 1
and you heard the tale of the ancients
just like the first people
lost the
walls of the ancient insidious
they awaken
if you give them free rein
this is love this is what the ancients called
love
everyday life
ancient home why are we here from our
city love your enemies
and who else could be a benefactor
maybe you are
in pic .
he arranged ways who want income
[music]